for years the meat industry has been
offering beef eaters three basic options
well done medium or rare but that's
changing beyond meat impossible foods
and some traditional food makers are now
targeting this market with a fourth
option meatless this new generation of
fake meat comes from plant-based
proteins but they're made to mimic the
real thing an investor's see so much
promise in these new products that
they're hoovering up the stocks beyond
meat shares have skyrocketed more than
500 percent since the company's IPO in
May think about that 500 percent this
puts the company's current value at
about 10 billion dollars that's more
than a hundred times their sales in 2018
and impossible foods another big player
in the meatless alternatives industry
recently raised another 300 million
dollars in funding these companies and
others are betting that people might
actually change the way they look at me
but are they right one thing that's
clear the market for meatless
alternatives is growing US retail sales
of plant-based foods from imitation
burgers to soy milk climbed to 4.5
billion dollars in one year rising about
11% and outpacing general retail food
sales by more than five times and sales
of meat alternatives topped 800 million
dollars these sales now make up about 2%
of all packaged meat sales some
investors expect the purchase price of
these foods to increase as the industry
takes off driving up sales even higher
so in a world where fake meat has been
around for decades why are customers
flocking to these new products beyond me
and impossible foods are marketing their
products differently from traditional
meatless alternatives like garden burger
they're aiming to feed meat eaters as
well as vegans and vegetarians since the
latter group makes up less than 5% of
the u.s. population in the u.s. today
there are many people who will never
give up me entirely but who still want
to eat less of it for people over 40
experts say health is the biggest
and why consumers want to add meatless
alternatives to their diet but for
Millennials who are driving the trend
the environment is the biggest reason
experts say that farming vegetables
releases less greenhouse gases than
livestock production and that eating
less meat helps stave off rising global
temperatures beyond me and impossible
foods are aiming to serve this market
giving investors the prospect of long
term growth to get excited about in an
effort to appeal to meat eaters
companies are trying to mimic the look
and taste of ground beef beyond meat for
example extracts proteins from yellow
peas and combines them with starches
oils and juices to produce patties that
convincingly sizzle though several
companies have designed products with
the goal of imitating real meat beyond
meat has taken the early lead the
initial success of beyond meat has
attracted big deals with major brands
making the product even more enticing to
investors Duncan and the Canadian coffee
chain Tim Hortons recently added
breakfast sandwiches made with beyond
meats imitation sausage Dunkin is
serving the product at some of its New
York City locations and Tim Hortons is
selling their sausage patty at about
4,000 Canadian locations and since 2017
beyond meat has struck deals to supply
burger patties to chains including TGI
Fridays del Taco restaurants and Carl's
jr. other companies have been slower to
attract big deals and when they do they
haven't always been able to follow
through many experts thought that
impossible foods had the better product
and message in the earlier stages but
production issues hurt them the company
had to apologize to restaurants like
Burger King and White Castle after
experiencing supply shortages while
beyond me also had shortage issues in
2017 and 2018 since then they've had a
clean track record
in June the company CEO said on an
earnings call that they were confident
they had the manufacturing lined up to
meet demand with all of be on meets
early success traditional food companies
have been lining up to develop similar
products companies best prepared to get
in on the market include Tyson Foods
Kanaga Brands Unilever and Nestle
according to an investor group but many
investors don't see these companies
posing a major threat to beyond me at
least for now
that's because beyond me is one of the
few companies in the stock market that's
purely focused on meat alternatives
companies with many products face more
diverse challenges for example if there
was a widespread ecoli contamination
among US cattle Tyson stock could go
down regardless of how much imitation
meat they sell beyond meat could be at
the cutting edge of an entirely new
industry there could be a whole new food
category that's being built out there
aren't many times you can say this it's
something new and tangible in spite of
this betting big on beyond meat in this
early stages is still risky that's
because the company could wind up facing
internal issues for example other hot
startups like Tesla saw their stock
prices increase quickly before taking a
tumble for now it's still too early to
tell if the meat alternatives industry
will take off the way that investors
expect it to but we'll be watching
[Music]
you
[Music]